[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france24
desde que los talibanes llegaron
nuevamente al poder en afganistán han
decretado una serie de medidas que
cercenan la libertad de las mujeres en
un retroceso que desaparece la lucha de
décadas en el país por la igualdad
el más reciente mandato de los
extremistas obliga a las trabajadoras de
los medios de comunicación a cubrirse el
rostro por completo mientras se están
llevando a cabo su oficio
la misión de derechos humanos de las
naciones unidas en afganistán es dijo
que el país enfrenta desafíos graves en
materia de derechos humanos y les pidió
a los talibanes que reviertan las
crecientes restricciones a las mujeres y
que investiguen los ataques contra las
minorías religiosas sin embargo no hay
garantías bajo un liderazgo inspirado
por la interpretación radical de la
sharía la invitada para conversar sobre
este tema es lourdes báez a ella fue
corresponsable en oriente medio durante
casi una década y hoy se conecta con
nosotros desde madrid españa lourdes
bienvenida a ellas hoy gracias por estar
con nosotros y la onu instó a los
talibanes a cerrar esa brecha entre sus
palabras y sus hechos pero por principio
la normalidad del talibán es la mentira
existe incluso una palabra específica
para ello en qué consiste esta filosofía
y entonces que podemos creer
exactamente saludas angela yo creo que
desde el momento en el que eeuu decidió
que la coalición abandonaba a afganistán
nadie dudaba de que este momento iba a
llegar el momento en el que se empezaran
a restringir los derechos de las mujeres
y se volviese a usar el burka en el país
no por nada en concreto sino porque la
filosofía talibán desde el principio es
así la interpretación de la ley islámica
porque no deja de ser una interpretación
es una interpretación radical que poco o
nada tiene que ver realmente con lo que
dice en los textos sagrados del corán
pero ya tenemos experiencia de ello
porque en el año 96 del 96 al 2001 así
lo hicieron y era de esperar que tras 20
años de lo que en afganistán para
nosotros la sociedad occidental ha sido
libertad para ellos ha sido todo lo
contrario intentas en revertir esa
situación y volver al estatus original
máxime cuando en afganistán
la salida de eeuu y de la coalición
internacional se interpreta como un
historia sobre lo que es el mundo
occidental que para ellos es como el
de cara a su interpretación de
cómo tiene que ser la vida y demás yo me
parece una noticia muy triste pero
también me parece algo que era
totalmente esperado y
que no se ha hecho nada realmente por
evitarlo es una lástima pero todos hemos
podido comprobar que así ha sido y nos
tememos realmente que vaya peor que
puede hacer peor por ahí quería hacerles
la siguiente pregunta el retroceso en
derechos humanos y en este caso en los
derechos de las mujeres ha sido evidente
y además ha sido descarado el cierre de
aulas para las niñas en la secundaria el
despido de mujeres de muchos de los
sectores laborales y productivos la
imposición del código de vestimenta por
mencionar solamente algunos de los
cambios y de los retrocesos
ahora las pocas mujeres que todavía
tienen algo de visibilidad en la
sociedad en público tienen que cubrirse
incluidas las periodistas y asia ya digo
me pregunta cuánto más se puede
deteriorar la situación hay posibilidad
de que algo cambie
esta semana hablaba precisamente con
algunas de esas periodistas
principalmente de la cadena tolo news
como játira ahmad y ellas temen que esto
solo sea un pequeño paso a erradicarlas
totalmente de la pantalla no olvidemos
que el símbolo de los talibán ha sido
por antonomasia del burka y el burka
cubre
la cabeza completamente lo que a ellas
les han obligado a ponerse ahora es más
un niqab algo que sólo deja los ojos al
descubierto pero ella es temen realmente
que ésta sea como una medida intermedia
para hacerles desaparecer de la pantalla
o hacerles aparecer con un burka lo cual
sería exactamente lo mismo porque bueno
las que en alguna ocasión hemos tenido
que llevar esta prenda hemos podido
comprobar que no sólo se anula
completamente a la mujer por no poder
verle el rostro es que es una prenda que
apenas te deja ver con lo cual dificulta
mucho el día a día
es algo totalmente
esperable de desgracia
muchas de ellas
han optado por cubrirse dejando
solamente los ojos al descubierto
principalmente porque sus propias
cadenas han recibido presiones de que
aquella que no lo hiciera pues ser
retirada de la pantalla o incluso perder
el trabajo ellas se han quedado porque
nos cuentan que realmente piensan que
pueden dar voz a las mujeres de alguna
manera aunque sea con el rostro cubierto
y no quieren perder esa pequeña
oportunidad que tienen no olvidemos que
esta medida va encaminada la mujer en
televisión es también un símbolo para el
resto de mujeres en afganistán que cada
vez tienen más restringido el espacio
público y su casa tiende a ser el único
sitio donde realmente se pueden sentir
seguras no olvidemos que no solamente
les han dejado
restringido el espacio público sino que
además una de las partes de ese decreto
viene a decir algo así como que
solamente salgan de casa si es necesario
quién determina qué es lo necesario o no
lo necesario existe también mucho miedo
a esa policía política llamada de la
virtud porque ya en la otra etapa en la
que gobernaban los talibán se dieron
casos de latigazos y de castigos
públicos simplemente pues porque una
ráfaga de viento les había levantado el
velo entonces se deja un poco al
arbitrio de esos policías que
desgraciadamente además no dudan a la
hora de imponer su criterio y de
castigar a una mujer en público las
mujeres lo saben por eso se temen que
cada vez van a salir menos las valientes
que lo hacen y no digamos las que
protestan se enfrentan realmente a
castigos muy duros contra su vida
incluso además de lo que nos hiciera
regresar sobre algo que usted mencionaba
y es que las mujeres probablemente ahora
sólo se sienten seguras en su casa pero
sobre esto pues yo no estoy tan segura
porque además de la invisibilidad de la
figura completamente de la mujer en lo
público puede ser aún más preocupante
que un gobierno que no le responde a
nadie sus acciones no se pueden
verificar no se pueden persuadir al
menos no se ha podido hasta el momento
pues qué va a pasar con las niñas y las
mujeres cada vez más vulnerables o yo
diría más vulnerables que nunca a la
violencia machista y si esto sucede
afuera pues dentro de la casa quien
controla qué
efectivamente ese es otro de los grandes
problemas puede suceder bueno hace poco
hablando con una colega que está en
naciones unidas nos comentaba que claro
estadísticamente por ejemplo en países
vecinos como pakistán no existen casos
denunciados de
asesinatos en el ámbito doméstico no es
porque no los haya es porque no se
denuncia y afganistán puede ir también
hacia ese camino porque en realidad si
la esfera en la que la mujer se podría
sentir segura es esa esfera doméstica y
realmente nos encontramos ante un país
en el que las leyes no protegen a esas
mujeres cualquier cosa que suceda en el
ámbito doméstico
está totalmente desprotegida es decir ni
siquiera tiene un sitio donde acudir una
asociación que le ayude no hablemos del
gobierno por supuesto muchas de estas
mujeres no podemos olvidarnos sobre todo
por ejemplo en el caso de las
presentadoras de televisión que
hablábamos son mujeres de veintipocos
años es decir mujeres que han crecido en
esa libertad que ahora se les va a
cercenar hay una generación ha habido 20
años en los que las mujeres han podido
estudiar han tenido por supuesto ciertas
restricciones sobre todo en el ámbito
rural porque no olvidemos que ha habido
esta libertad no ha sido en todo el país
ni mucho menos pero bueno han podido
estudiar que no es poco' han podido
salir a la calle sin estar acompañadas
de un padre o un hermano o un familiar
varón todo esto se acabó no solo se
acabó sino que además es muy importante
la parte que de la que estamos hablando
de que en el ámbito doméstico también
existe una desprotección total dependen
de su relación en este caso con el
marido o con los hombres la familia
porque no olvidemos que no es sólo el
marido o el padre estos días no sé si
han estado al tanto en españa existe una
conmoción muy grande porque ha habido
dos jóvenes criadas en españa pero de
origen pakistaní a las que se ha llevado
a su país engañadas para casarlas con
dos primos y al final pues como se han
negado las han asesinado existe una
investigación sobre esto en españa
porque hay familiares que han colaborado
y que se cree que algunos de ellos son
familiares de los que viven aquí pero
realmente no se ha podido hacer nada
esta es un tema muy delicado en el que
incluso las autoridades internacionales
naciones unidas- poco realmente pueden
hacer porque las presiones se limitan a
las sanciones de tipo económico que al
final a quienes realmente perjudican es
a la propia población a la que se quiere
proteger porque no olvidemos que en
afganistán existe el índice de pobreza
es
muy alto
hay que valorar un poco si esas
sanciones al final no van a ser peor el
remedio que la enfermedad en estos días
desde que sucedió esto de hecho y perdón
que la interrumpa pues se dispararon los
matrimonios infantiles se disparó la
llamada venta de mujeres pues de las
familias que no tenían otra manera de
subsistir y pues para ellos y dentro de
su situación pues la única manera era
vender mujeres así es no olvidemos que
muchas de estas familias lo hacen
realmente por necesidad
porque ven en esas niñas la manera de
arreglar la situación económica y
familiar entonces es muy complicado
también cuando vemos a auténticos
señores de la guerra reunidos con
representantes de naciones unidas y de
la comunidad internacional
es muy desesperante porque realmente
poco se puede hacer
esa ayuda que se les está dando es
necesaria ampliar las sanciones como
digo es muy delicado y las pocas
personas que están trabajando desde
dentro se enfrentan a dificultades cada
vez mayores incluso bueno como decían
antes hay gente que puede enfrentar la
pena de muerte no sabemos hasta dónde va
a llegar esto pero todo indica que va a
ser una escalada porque bajo la visión
de los talibán ellos han tenido como 20
años de lo que ellos considerarían que
ha sido sodoma y gomorra con lo cual
están cada vez más empeñados en revertir
y que vuelvan a los valores
tradicionales como digo con una
interpretación totalmente errónea y
radical de lo que es el islam pues la
verdad es que al final de estos
programas y ya se nos acabó el tiempo lo
que nos gusta en ellas hoy es hacer
conclusiones del tema pero ante todo lo
que usted nos está diciendo y que
tampoco era para nada inesperado como lo
dijo al principio del programa lo que se
siente es una altísima frustración y las
manos completamente atadas de todas
maneras le agradezco ustedes por hablar
con nosotros y por visibilizar a las
mujeres que hoy están escondiendo en
afganistán muchas gracias a ustedes y
gracias a nuestros televidentes por
estar con nosotros y nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]